et alors celle ci
si la grande ourse et fessiers la grande
qui brille là bas c'est la terre etc
cela
interne et plus vivable comme elle
l'était et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
partis mais participent à ce que vous
voulez quelque chose de mieux
on a de la chance d'avoir cet endroit
ouais là ne posera aussi ok tu manges
pas si
tu vois quelque chose
un décret me way
tu viens la porte derrière moi
[Musique]
cette maison c'est pas la vôtre
mais j'ai même fait un long voyage
maintenant je reste là vous pouvez
partir si vous voulez on peut sauver
alors
hambourg est impossible
donc tu veux savoir ce qu'il y as d'or
que dalle
et c'est le seul endroit qui reste
il des autres colonies a plus rien
plus tôt tu l'acceptera plus tôt tu
réaliseras
tout ce qu'il nous faut ici